my bingo
to say Park young sick is a Super Fan is
too understated by a long mile
his barbecue restaurant is a shrine to
football South Korea and his lifelong
Devotion to both
he attended his first World Cup in 1994
in the U.S and was hooked
I achieved my dream of cheering my side
I thought that would be it go and then
return to my original life but I went
crazy this world cup will be his 60th
trip after his beloved team whose patchy
performance can result in mixed moments
of sometimes ecstasy often Agony is this
happy sad happy happy
[Laughter]
when you win you can't put it into words
that feeling of joy and Elation but if
we lose I'm so deeply saddened it's very
hard
and his proudest moments
in 2012 our men's team won the bronze at
the London Olympics that's the most
memorable of all the cheering trips I
have taken overseas and of course taking
pride of places Park's photo of himself
with Superstar captain and Tottenham
Striker son hung Min coming from a poor
upbringing park has for decades been
helping out at a local orphanage and for
the past few World Cups has been taking
one lucky youngster from here with him
each time
going to Qatar is 16 year old parkubin
I've been to a lot of local games but
this will be the first time abroad so I
will cheer extra hard
whether the tagok Warriors progress from
the group stage Park will have to be
back in 10 days his business and his
marriage he says can't afford more
uh
my wife told me to sign the divorce
papers before I go to Qatar but I told
her I'll do it when I get back because I
know I can change your mind when I
return
Korea
the price some pay for the Love of the
Game Rob McBride Al Jazeera dejeon South
Korea